which deadpool sidekick got a makeover
for the movies that ended up changing
the comics how did the mcu go about
individualizing the eternals you'll be
shocked to see which superhero powers
did and didn't translate from page to
screen
when superman the movie hit theaters in
1978 its tagline was you'll believe a
man can fly well if you can believe it
superman hasn't always been the flying
hero we know today no his first few
appearances characterized his levitation
abilities just a little bit differently
faster than a speeding bullet
more powerful than a locomotive
able to leave tall buildings at a single
bound instead of being able to fly
around hover and turn on a dime like the
superman we know today the original
superman was still subject to the laws
of gravity this version could jump up to
the top of a mountain with ease but
keeping up with an airplane was a bit
more of a challenge for him the big
change didn't come about until max
fleischer who produced the famous betty
boop and popeye cartoons adapted the
character into animated serials in the
1940s it turns out that animating
superman constantly jumping in the air
was beyond the technology of the era and
would have been too expensive to produce
having the heroes simply fly through the
sky was bound to be both easier and
cheaper to animate superman's comic book
counterparts soon followed suit and the
rest as they say is history
spider-man has been swinging around new
york since 1962's amazing fantasy issue
15. and to do it he almost always had to
use mechanical web shooters and
specially designed web fluid while many
fans prefer this take on their character
it was always a bit of a stretch that a
young man struggling to pay rent somehow
had the resources to craft devices so
advanced it would also have made perfect
sense for peter parker to have gained
web powers from his radioactive spider
bites along with his other abilities
climbing on walls super strength
enhanced perception none of which are as
spider-specific as web spinning is when
james cameron was tasked with writing
and directing a spider-man feature film
in the early 1990s one of his biggest
adaptation changes was turning the
hero's web shooters from mechanical to
organic when that version of the film
fell apart and director sam raimi took
over raymie decided to keep the organic
web shooter idea cameron introduced
after the film's blockbuster success
marvel comics introduced to mutation
elements to make parker's web shooters
organic as well
but it didn't last long the
controversial 2007 event storyline one
more day erased the mutations and
restored the original gadgets subsequent
spider-man reboot films have also
reinstated their mechanical nature
that came out of you yeah
you can't do that huh no most of what
makes kamala khan such a fan favorite
comic book character namely her
fangirling over superheroes and being an
awkward but endearing daydreamer seems
to remain intact in the disney plus
adaptation her arsenal of powers however
appears to have been completely revamped
for the show in the comics can't come
polymorph which usually manifests in her
stretching or growing outer limbs to
superhuman size however it was decided
that the mcu version of the character
would instead create glowing energy
constructs like a green lantern there
are many reasons and a lot of
speculation as to why marvel and disney
might have made this change for the show
some fans think her powers were changed
to be more similar to brie larson's
captain marvel while others theorized
that her original powers were too close
to those of mr fantastic from the
fantastic four whatever the case may be
the rest of the show seems to be
relatively comics accurate at least for
now
even though sam wilson aka falcon hasn't
had a solo film yet he's still a fan
favorite due to anthony mackie seen
stealing performances in captain america
the winter soldier and a handful of
subsequent mcu films he eventually got
his title role alongside bucky barnes in
the disney plus show the falcon and the
winter soldier
which ended with the character taking up
the mantle of captain america in the mcu
falcon is just a regular human soldier
with a special jetpack shaped like a
pair of wings hence the name he can
certainly go toe-to-toe with a number of
super beings thanks to his military
training but he doesn't actually have
any superpowers himself falcon has a
single superpower in the comics however
the ability to talk to birds most often
this would be red wink falcon's avian
sidekick who helps him fight crime but
it's also been extended to birds of all
kinds red wing has appeared in the
movies in the form of a mechanical drone
but that hasn't stopped wilson from
treating the robot like it's an actual
bird
thank you don't thank me
i'm not thinking that thing his name is
redwing i'm still not thinking he's cute
the decision to take away sam wilson's
avian communication abilities is
definitely one of the more
understandable changes the mcu has made
marvel entertainment head honcho kevin
feige has stated that wonder maximoff is
the most powerful character in the
entire mcu he has a point she
psychically manipulated the hulk and
nearly took down thanos all on her own
as powerful as she is in the mcu the
scarlet witch is exponentially more
powerful in the comics there she's a
mutant with the ability to literally
alter reality to the point that she
wiped out 90 percent of the mutant
population in the 2005 event series
house of m in the films her powers so
far have been mostly limited to an
extremely broad definition of
telekinesis some vague telepathic
abilities and shooting off bolts of
mysterious red energy in the 2021 disney
plus show one division the scarlet witch
finally got closer to her comic book
powers creating her own artificial
reality and resurrecting her android
lover vision she reaches even more
destructive heights in dr strange in the
multiverse of madness which marks an
important turning point for the powerful
magic user
it can be reasonably argued that 1998's
blade starring wesley snipes in the
title role is a comic book film that
helped kick off the current domination
of superhero movies today while movies
adapted from comics had certainly been
successful in the past blade was one of
the first that wasn't based on a
household name like batman or superman
in fact he was relatively obscure blade
was also the first big hit to feature a
marvel comics character leading to
studios eventually taking a chance on
x-men and spider-man in the films blade
is a day walker a half vampire with all
of a vampire strengths and none of their
weaknesses in the original comics
however he was basically just a regular
human with a love for edged weapons and
an immunity from vampire bites while the
movies kept the backstory that blade's
mother was bitten by a vampire while
pregnant with him they changed the exact
effects that the bites had on baby blade
after the success of the films however
marvel comics changed blade's powers to
more closely align with the version
played by snipes which is now the iconic
image of the character
it's pretty obvious at this point that
ryan reynolds was born to play deadpool
marvel's resident merc with a mouth even
though 2016's deadpool and its 2018
sequel deadpool 2 hewed pretty close to
the comics especially concerning the
character of deadpool himself those
weren't the first times reynolds played
the character in 2009's x-men origins
wolverine reynolds played wade wilson in
a motor mouth characterization that was
broadly accurate however this is before
wilson turns into deadpool in the last
act and things really start to go off
the rails the film's version of deadpool
looked nothing like his comic book
counterpart his power set included both
teleportation and cyclops's concussion
beam and worst of all they closed his
mouth for good this is probably one of
the most egregious character
assassinations in the history of
superhero films and it's no surprise
that this particular take on deadpool is
nothing more than a punchline nowadays
we're also your pretty mouth shirt
oh
i wouldn't do that if i were you
although deadpool's character was pretty
accurate in the deadpool films one
character who had a major change to her
powers when blasting off from page to
screen was his team's sidekick negasonic
teenage warhead named after a monster
magnet song and played by brianna
hildebrand ntw bears little resemblance
to the version seen in the marvel comics
universe in the comics negasonic teenage
warhead was originally a mutant with
precognitive and telepathic powers in
the deadpool films however her powers
change to something more befitting her
explosive name namely the ability to
generate explosive charges from her body
these new powers are similar to the
comic book character of cannonball who
the filmmakers originally considered
including in her place however they
ultimately thought it would be more fun
to have the character be a sardonic goth
girl to contrast deadpool's manic energy
and of course he also loved her name the
end result of all this was that
negasonic teenage warhead originally an
extremely minor comics character killed
off in every first issue was brought
back for the marvel comics series
deadpool and the mercs for money there
she was given an appearance and power
set that matches the one seen in the
deadpool movies
it can't be overstated how ubiquitous
image comic spawn was in the early to
mid 1990s his face was all over t-shirts
toys video games posters and of course
comics this was even more impressive
considering how mature the comics
themselves were featuring edgy themes
and depictions of graphic violence this
popularity led inevitably to a big
budget feature film from new line cinema
in 1997.
to the film's credits it's actually
fairly accurate to the comic book
following u.s special agent al simmons
after he's betrayed and killed by his
evil bus
turned into a hellspawn by the demon
malbolger it's spawn's job to lead hell
in a war against heaven there's only one
real change made for the adaptation but
it's a pretty big one the necroplasm
counter in the comics spawn's powers
comes from the necroplasm in his suit
which if fully depleted would send him
permanently back to hell with no chance
for escape this means that despite his
demonic abilities being extremely
powerful he has to be mindful of how he
uses them on earth while the movie does
incorporate the concept of necroplasm
spawn doesn't have to ration a finite
amount of it meaning the film has to
rely on other sources of dramatic
tension perhaps the necroplasm counter
will finally appear on screen in the
spawn reboot film that is if it ever
actually gets made
give my regards to your boss
tell him he's next the original eternals
comic series written and drawn by
legendary artist jack kirby is about a
group of powerful and immortal godlike
beings who are the bases of human myths
and legends they were sent down to
ancient earth by even more powerful
celestial beings to protect humans
throughout history from the monstrous
deviants all the heroes in the group
shared similar powers each of the
eternals possesses super strength
invulnerability flight telepathy and a
myriad of other magical abilities of
course certain characters were better at
certain abilities than others but they
otherwise shared relatively equivalent
powers however for the star-studded 2021
feature film eternals the decision was
made to split these super powers among
the heroes giving each their own unique
ability only icarus can fly only cersei
can transmute objects only makari has
super speed and so on this helps
differentiate the eternals and made the
film generally less cluttered and
confusing than it might have been
otherwise
while the superhero film on the surface
zhang chi and the legend of the 10 rings
succeeds by being a fun fantasy martial
arts film first and foremost the stunts
and fights are visceral and brutal while
the narrative is a thoughtful personal
story about family and tradition in the
source material xiangxi is likely the
greatest martial arts master on the
planet the closest thing to superpowers
xiangxi possesses is his ability to
harness his chi but it's implied that
anyone could potentially do that as well
if they trained hard enough see mouliu's
take on chongqi is close enough to the
original but the major change of the
film comes in the form of his signature
weapons the 10 rings in the comics the
10 rings are literal rings that are worn
on each finger each of which has its own
unique power the 10 rings in the mcu are
more like conduits for energy that can
be used as whips projectiles and
propulsion plus they're worn primarily
on the forearms rather than on the
fingers it's unclear exactly how much of
this change was a result of a desire to
wreck on certain aspects of iron man 3
but whatever the reason might be we're
not complaining
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]